three children all with their own
personalities and as we've seen recently
their own way of doing things
now prince george princess charlotte and
prince louis will have one thing in
common they're all heading to the same
school from september this is where
they're going lambrook a private school
just outside windsor that takes boys and
girls from three to thirteen
set in the berkshire countryside william
and kate hope it'll give them some more
freedom away from what one royal source
described as the goldfish bowl of
kensington palace and living in london
in fact a new school means another new
home and one much closer to the queen
with the cambridges moving to adelaide
cottage on the windsor estate
they are paying the rent privately but
also keeping their other homes in london
and norfolk
not necessarily a great look during the
cost of living crisis but a decision
we're told they've made to try to
balance raw duties with what's best for
their children
when you look back you get a better
understanding of why william's childhood
was a much more public affair and he
wants more privacy for his three so
while the young cambridges are gradually
being introduced to all that the start
of the latest chapter in their school
careers will like last time be low-key
with maybe a little something for the
cameras when term finally starts in
september
rhiannon mills sky news